there's a thought experiment um and i
actually want to hear what you think so
if a witch kind of a dickish
witch comes around and she says
i'm gonna cast a spell on all of
humanity and all material things that
you've invented
are going to disappear all at once so
suddenly we're all standing there naked
there's no buildings
there's there's there's no cars and
boats and ships and no mines nothing
right
it's just the stone age earth and a
bunch of naked humans but we're all the
same we have the same brain so we all
know what's going on and we all got a
note from her so we understand the deal
and she says um she communicated to
every human here's the deal you lost all
your stuff
you guys need to make one working iphone
13.
when you make one working iphoto 13 that
could pass in the apple store today you
know in your previous world for an
iphone 13 then i will restore everything
how long do you think and so everyone
knows this is this is the mission we're
all aware of the mission everyone all
humans
how long would it take us that's a
really interesting question so obviously
if you do a random selection of hundred
or a thousand humans within the
population i think you're screwed
to make that iphone
i tend to believe that there's
fascinating specialization
among the human civilization like
there's a few hackers out there
that can like solo build an iphone
but with what materials
so no materials whatsoever
it has to i mean it's it's virtually i
mean okay you have to build factories i
mean to right and to fabricate
okay
and how are you gonna mine them you know
you got to mine the materials where you
know how many cranes you don't need you
know okay you 100 have to have the this
everybody's naked everyone's naked and
everyone's where they are so you and i
would currently be naked uh it's on the
ground in what used to be manhattan
building brassy no grassy island yeah um
so you need a naked elon musk type
character to then start building a
company yes you have to have a large
company then right it doesn't even know
where he you know where is everyone you
know how am i going to find other
people i need to we have all the
knowledge of yeah everyone has the
knowledge that's in their current brains
yeah i've met some legit
engineers
crazy polymath people yeah
but the actual labor of me because you
said
because like the
the original
mac like the apple ii
that could be built
but
even that you know even that's gonna be
tough well i think part of it is a
communication problem if you could
suddenly have you know someone if
everyone had a walkie-talkie and there
was you know a couple you know ten
really smart people were designated the
leaders they could say okay i want you
know everyone who can do this to to walk
west you know until you get to this this
little hub and everyone else you know
and they could they could actually
coordinate but we don't have that so
it's like people just you know and then
what i think about is so you've got some
people that are like trying to organize
and you'll have a little community where
a couple hundred people have come
together and maybe a couple thousand
have organized and they designated one
person you know as the leader and then
they have sub leaders and okay
we have a start here we have some
organization you're also going to have
some people that say good
humans were scourge upon the earth and
this is good and they're going to try to
sabotage they're trying to murder the
people with the and who know what
they're talking about
it uh the elite that yeah that possessed
the knowledge yeah well and so everyone
maybe everyone's hopeful for you know
we're all civilized and hopeful for the
first 30 days or something and then
things start to fall off you know people
get start to lose hope and there's new
kinds of new kinds of governments
popping up you know new kinds of
societies and they're they're they're
they're you know
and they don't play nicely with the
other ones and and i think very quickly
i think a lot of people just give up and
say you know what this is it we're back
in the stone age let's just create you
know agrarian we don't also don't know
how to farm no one knows how to farm
there's like the even the even the
farmers you know a lot of them are
relying on their machines um and uh so
we also usually mass starvation and that
you know when you're trying to organize
a lot of people are you know coming in
with you know spears they've fashioned
and trying to murder everyone who has an
interesting question given today's
society how much violence would that be
we've gotten softer or less violent and
we don't have weapons
really primitive weapons now but we have
a and also we have a kind of ethics
where murder is bad
we used to be less like human life was
less valued
murder was more okay like ethically but
in the past they also were really good
at figuring out how to have sustenance
they knew how to get food and water
because they they
so we have no idea like the ancient
hunter gatherer societies would laugh at
what's going on here they say you guys
know you don't know what you're none of
you know what you're doing yeah and also
the amount of people feeding this amount
of people uh in in a very in a stone age
you know civilization that's not gonna
happen so new york and san francisco are
screwed well whoever's not near water is
really screwed so that's something
you're near a river a freshwater river
and you know anyway it's a very
interesting question and what it does
this and the pencil
it makes me
um
feel so grateful and like excited about
like man our civilization is so
cool and this is talk about collective
intelligence
humans did not
build any of this it's collective human
super collective humans is a super
intelligent you know uh being that is
that can do absolutely especially over a
long period of time can do such magical
things and we just get to be born
when i go out when i'm working and i'm
hungry i just go click click click and
like a salad is coming
the salad arrives if you think about the
incredible infrastructure that's in
place for that for that quickly just the
internet to you know the electricity
first of all that's just powering the
things you know how the where the amount
of structures that have to be created
and for that electricity to be there and
then you've got the of course the
internet and then you have this system
um where delivery drivers and they have
they're running bikes that were made by
someone else and they're going to get
the salad and all those ingredients came
from all over the place i mean it's just
so i think it's like i i like thinking
about these things because it um it
makes me feel like
just so grateful i'm like man it would
be so awful if we didn't have this and
people people who didn't have it would
think this was such magic we live in and
we do and like cool that's
fun
you